pensemos esta vez en una función y vamos
a ponerle un nombre voy a suponer que se
llama h hdn y esta función va a ser
igual y no sé se me ocurre a un cuarto
que multiplica a 2 elevado a la potencia
n entonces primero que nada lo que
puedes observar es que en esta ocasión
tenemos a la variable de entrada de
nuestra función en el exponente y esto
está bastante interesante porque este
tipo de funciones se les conoce con el
nombre de función exponencial es más
déjame ponerle nombre esta de aquí es
una función exponencial
es una función exponencial y esto se
debe a que la variable de entrada de
nuestra función está definida en el
exponente y con ella viviendo aquí en el
exponente obtenemos nuestra variable de
salida y puedo escribir no sé no se me
ocurre otra función exponencial así que
se me ocurre ahora tomarme la siguiente
función exponencial y en esta ocasión mi
variable de entrada va a ser t entonces
efe dt efe dt va a ser igual y no sé se
me ocurre pensar en 5 por 3 elevado a la
potencia t y una vez más esta también es
una función exponencial y ahora hay un
par de cosas interesantes en que pensar
acerca de una función exponencial de
hecho vamos a explicar todas ellas pero
primero lo que quiero es que nos
acostumbremos un poco a la terminología
entonces la primera cosa de la que
quiero hablar
la noción o la idea del valor inicial
así que déjame escribirlo por aquí voy a
hablar del valor inicial y bueno el
valor inicial esencialmente es el valor
de la función cuando la entrada es cero
entonces para estos casos el valor
inicial de la función h
es cuando n va a valer cero entonces h
de cero va a ser igual y si sustituimos
este valor aquí arriba me va a quedar un
cuarto un cuarto que multiplica a dos
elevado a la potencia cero y cuánto es
esto bueno pues dos el a cero
simplemente esto es 1 así que
simplemente me va a quedar un cuarto por
uno lo cual es un cuarto entonces el
valor inicial al menos en este caso
parece ser este número que tenemos aquí
es decir el número que se pone aquí
tenemos el valor inicial que multiplica
a un cierto número elevado a este
exponente que es nuestra variable de
entrada
y después veremos el nombre de este
número pero vamos a ver si eso es cierto
también para efe dt vamos a ver cuánto
es
efe de 0 y bueno efe de 0 va a ser lo
mismo que si sustituimos 5 por 3 elevado
a la cero pero una vez más 13 elevado a
0 esto es simplemente 1 y me va a quedar
5 por 1 lo cual es 5 y aquí está es de
nuevo este valor inicial que tengo aquí
entonces si tienes funciones
exponenciales de esta forma tiene
sentido su valor inicial va a ser bueno
si pones 0 en estos exponentes esto
siempre va a ser 1 y entonces este
número que está multiplicando va a ser
tu valor inicial solo te quedarás con
esta cosa que está multiplicando y
espero que esto tenga un poco de sentido
para ti o que al menos me puedas
entender un poquito pero en fin vamos a
ver mejor cómo se llama este número que
tenemos aquí
este número que tenemos aquí y bueno
tiene un nombre su nombre es razón común
déjame ponerlo aquí razón común
y en mi cerebro me pregunto bueno por
qué se llama una razón común y pues la
respuesta es la siguiente si piensas que
nuestras entradas son números enteros
especialmente en entradas de números
enteros secuenciales dicho de otra
manera una sucesión verás un patrón por
ejemplo si quiero tomarme 70 bueno ya
sabemos cuántos h de cero no h de 0 es
lo mismo que un cuarto bien y qué pasa
si quiero tomarme hd 1
bueno pues hd 1 va a ser lo mismo que un
cuarto por 2 elevado a la primera
potencia pero eso es lo mismo que un
cuarto que multiplica a 2 estás de
acuerdo y bueno
observa que esto es lo mismo que 2 por h
por h de 0 ok y si quiero hablar del hd2
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que un
cuarto que multiplica a quien bueno va a
multiplicar a 2 elevado al cuadrado que
es lo mismo que 2
2 o de otra manera observa que esto es
lo mismo que m2 por hd 1 esto es lo
mismo que dos por h de 1 y es que de
esta manera puedes observar que si
sacamos la razón entre hd2 y hd 1
bueno pues esa razón va a ser 2 y si
tomamos la razón entre hd 1 y hd 0 esa
razón también será este valor de 2 por
eso esta es la razón común entre las
entradas enteras sucesivas de nuestra
función e inclusive lo podemos ver de la
siguiente manera si pensamos no sé en
cuánto es h de n más
esto dividido entre h de nm bueno
inclusive esto mismo lo podemos
sustituir aquí me va a quedar un cuarto
un cuarto que multiplica a 2 elevado a
la n 1 elevado a la n más 1 y esto a su
vez dividido entre un cuarto un cuarto
que multiplica a 2 elevado a la potencia
en la potencia n bueno estos dos se
cancelan y simplemente voy a quedarme
con dos a la n 1 entre 2 a la n lo cual
sabemos que es 2 y es por eso que esta
es mi razón común bueno esto para la
función
hdn para la función f de nuestra razón
común sería 3 muy bien y qué pasaría si
lo hubiéramos de la manera contrario
imagínate que alguien nos dice vamos a
hablar de una función la cual es una
función exponencial y le voy a poner el
nombre
y bueno esta función exponencial gm
tiene como valor inicial como valor
inicial no sé se me ocurre que sea
-cinco inicial- su valor inicial es
igual a 5 y también voy a decir que esta
función g tiene como razón común como
razón común el valor de 6 entonces
déjame anotar lo tengo como razón común
el valor de 6 y bueno me dicen que es
una función exponencial entonces como se
va a ver esta función exponencial bueno
se va a ver de la siguiente manera se va
a ver no sé supongamos que nuestra
variable de entrada es x así que en esta
ocasión voy a tener que gtx va a ser
igual a el valor inicial que es 5 que
multiplica a la razón común elevada a la
potencia x así que una vez más observa
que aquí tenemos el valor inicial que es
este de aquí y que también estamos
hablando de una
son común esta de aquí la cual la
estamos colocando justo aquí y ya está
espero que todo esto te haya hecho
familiarizarte con la idea de una
función exponencial y con algunas partes
de esta y también espero que entiendas
un poco porque estas funciones se llaman
cómo se llaman